mais il n'est pas si chaud que ça dans
ce four à bois le résultat de plusieurs
mois de travail vaz bouteille saladier
chacun des 80 objets en céramique est
délicatement extrait de la chaleur sous
l'oeil avisé de leur créatrice là j'ai
utilisé une terre que j'ai pas
l'habitude d'utiliser mais voilà je
trouve aussi c'est une transe en plus de
67 côté là que de là où ce genre
d'événement n'a lieu qu'une fois par an
durant 65 heures les céramiques ont été
exposés à une chaleur pouvant aller
jusqu'à 1300 degrés afin de surveiller
le bon déroulement de la cuisson il a
fallu se relayer jour et nuit c'est une
émotion pendant toute la cuisson 5 il ya
quelque chose qui se joue de voilà deux
ans de travail qui à ce moment là va se
faire figée par le feu pendant quatre
jours on est là un maître dubois toutes
les 5 minutes 10 minutes ou un quart
d'heure en fonction de là où on en est
on écoute les petits crépitements moi
j'ai fait la première nuit et je vais
tout seul et c'était trop bien pendant
toute la nuit de du coup minuit à 7h et
puis je suis là avec le feu ces cas le
travail de plein d'artistes ce jour là
le résultat final est plus que
satisfaisant et les visiteurs présents
sont conquis par ses céramiques aux
formes diverses c'est un travail très
original donc très organique et ça c'est
un simple est donc je vais je vais
présenter ça à paris c'est plein de
sensibilité en fait c'est le plaisir de
la céramique avec à la fois
faire et la magie de ce qui sort du four
avec la transformation après cuisson les
couleurs les formes là le toucher alors
que ses pieds sont encore chaudes alors
il y avait caché sous tellement vivant
passé c'est magique magic os est
vraiment c'est magique et c'est l'essai
magnifique superbe au village de la
borne renommée pour ses céramiques
depuis le xiième siècle ils sont près de
70 à faire perdurer ce savoir faire
ancestral